if you thought you would be able to get
ethan hawk to spill some marvel secrets
you thought wrong yeah while appearing
on the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon ethan did his best to stay as
tight-lipped as possible when jimmy
pressed him about fan theories
surrounding his villainous new character
arthur harrow from the disney plus
series moon night
this could actually this could actually
get you in trouble all right i signed an
nda but let's see there is a uh
there's a fan theory that the hulk will
appear in moon night
that would be cool right that would be
cool except i know mark ruffalo and i
think if we were in the same show he
would have at least texted me or
something so i don't think that one's
got a lot of legs
i know i know maybe another one we
didn't buy we didn't buy that we uh we
think
that's right exactly they did yeah all
right there's a fan theory that blade
will appear in moon knight
stop now you're playing with it now
you're playing now you just play with me
yeah yeah would you got a text from
blade yeah i don't know i don't know
i wish blade was there i would have been
cool okay
pretty good this uh the third one's the
last one this this is my favorite fan
theory this one says since not a lot is
known about your character arthur harrow
some fans speculate that arthur harrow
is a decoy name and you're actually
playing the villain dracula
that is awesome
i so want that to be true i mean i i but
your expectation is so intense i want to
say yes so bad
i am dracula oh wow this is unbelievable
you heard it here first to hell with the
lawyers dracula it is god all right so
you so you all right so that one all
right good yeah so you're not i want to
be dracula so bad
i'm so confused he's such a pro i love
that yeah i love that okay while he may
be keeping quiet about the fan theories
ethan did tell me recently that the
mystery behind his character was what
made it so fun to play
your character you know like fans like
myself who know everything about these
universes and the books always look for
connections but did you find a freedom
in playing someone who
is not entirely in line with everything
like fans might know we were given
permission to go cut our own path you
know the thing about moon knight is it's
not very well known even in the comics
they constantly shifting exactly who he
is and what the story line is and what
his backstory is and he doesn't have one
main identifiable villain that was an
obvious place to start so we just
we got to forge our own
our own path
and
i think that's what made it so fun for
oscar and myself
and fun for all of us i mean you know
this about me i know this a lot about
you theory stuff around all of these
superhero uh movies is like one of my
favorite things you just love to be like
what if who did that could you imagine
is it a thing
i know nothing you're not like a geek
about it but you're a fun geek you're
you love it i love it and what's cool
about um so it's funny because on fallon
you know we know that andrew garfield
came out and was like i'm not in
um the way they're doing it here with
ethan and him you know having fun with
the dracula thing and the lawyers thing
is really great um i did get a chance to
see the first four episodes now the
moonlight is on premieres on the 30th i
saw the first four episodes already and
tight-lipped i can't say anything about
it
but with what's killing me about is that
now i've got to wait
like five weeks right because you're
really you've messed yourself up i've
messed myself up so i've seen i've they
got me to a cliffhanger a bit and now i
gotta wait all this time then you could
just re-watch it and like have all those
feelings again and then be like poop
well you know what's gonna happen
because what happens to people like me
that love this stuff you watch it the
first time you go oh and then watch the
second time you go oh yeah i didn't see
that oh i didn't see that and
texting with your friends it's all the
things all in the middle of the night
it's like a team sport
team's like a whole activity i love
activities yeah